le nombre d'exécutions en baisse de 5%
par rapport à 2018
c'est la tendance du dernier rapport
d'amnesty international sur la peine de
mort dans le monde
en france la pratique a été abolie en
quelques années après la dernière
exécution bonjour un condamné à mort a
donc été exécuté ce matin à la prison
des baumettes à marseille 10 septembre
1977 à 4h40 exactement la lame de la
guillotine ton pour la dernière fois
dans une prison française
hamida djandoubi un ouvrier agricole de
28 ans originaire de tunisie avaient été
jugés et condamnés en février dernier
pour assassinat viol coups et blessures
des crimes perpétrés sur sa maîtresse de
20 ans si hamida djandoubi reconnaît
rapidement les faits il n'échappe pas à
la condamnation à mort en 2007
l'un de ses avocats maître goudard haut
raconte l exécution de son client
nous étions une quinzaine tous deux vont
naturellement bon et un trépied beau
bleu comme ce soit et avec le beau rôle
et 2es derrière lui alors on lui des
tâches les mains en lui demande si une
cigarette ils veulent une cigarette
une deuxième il enlevait une troisième
la troisième cigarette lui sera refusée
tout comme la grâce présidentielle la
veille de son exécution par valéry
giscard d'estaing
un coup dur pour les avocats de jandoubi
je savais que la peine de mort devait
abroger à la rentrée et je me disais
mais je suis le dernier
donc on va pas le condamner à mort le
faire exécuter au moment de l'exécution
du jeune homme le débat sur la peine de
mort est vif en france le pays est
encore marquée par la très médiatisée
affaire ranucci cet homme exécuté en
1976 alors que sa culpabilité et
discuter
des centaines de français prennent alors
part au combat mais certains restent
difficiles à convaincre
tout ce qui est un crime crapuleux y a
pas d'hésitation je suis pour la peine
de me voir et je crois que dans tout mon
entourage
c'est l'avis unanime après la mise à
mort d'anita jandoubi plus d'une dizaine
de criminels sont encore condamné à mort
en france mais plus aucun ne sera
exécuté en 1979 robert badinter
abolitionniste convaincu et avocat de
plusieurs d'entre eux évoqué le début
d'une prise de conscience depuis la
rentrée judiciaire c'est-à-dire depuis
le 15 septembre
huit fois on a demandé la mort et huit
fois les jurés l'ont refusé c'est ça le
fait ce n'est pas le propre des avocats
ou des avocats généraux ce qui est
important c'est l'attitude des jurés
deux ans plus tard robert badinter nommé
ministre de la justice présente à
l'assemblée son projet de loi pour
l'abolition de la peine capitale
le texte est adopté le 18 septembre 1980
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]